so continuing to do and not as he says
he will do Donald Trump's 2019 deficit
is on track to reach the 1 trillion
dollar mark despite Trump having told us
you might remember time and time and
time again that he's going to fix the
deficit that Barack Obama ruined that he
will pay off the debt altogether if
given eight years in office and the time
that he thinks he will need to do it now
anyone who understands these issues even
remotely knew that it was never going to
happen and in fact it's getting worse
and worse as I've said before though we
really need to be reframing our
conversations about this issue of debt
and deficit altogether so let's start
with the facts and then we'll get into
the analysis and the sort of meaning of
all of this the White House itself is
now predicting that the deficit is going
to exceed a trillion dollars this year
the deficit has never hit a trillion
dollars in a year now anytime we talk
about these numbers this is not a
partisan this is not to make this worse
or not as bad as it is this is just
understanding when we hear the deficit
has never reached X number of dollars
before we need to understand number one
inflation adjusted numbers so that we're
really comparing apples to apples it's
also important to understand the size of
the deficit as a percentage of the
economy's total size and not in a vacuum
just a few things if we really want to
do this seriously now let's go back to
what Donald Trump said that he would do
when Trump was a candidate he said
number one he would eliminate the
deficit altogether and he would get us a
surplus partially he would do it by
cutting taxes for the rich and
corporations which he said would
generate so much growth that government
Rett tax revenues would actually expand
and there would be all this winning and
we would have a surplus and we would
start paying off the debt that obviously
never happened and it's important to
understand like if you want to talk
about this at all I hate that I have to
do this but you really need to
understand the difference between debt
and deficit okay and I I apologize to
those who are sick of me doing this but
when I don't do this and even sometimes
when I do this the comments that I get
in reaction to debt and deficit stories
are so confused about the difference
between the
to terms so these are not the same
things deficit is the one-year surplus
versus deficit that the country may have
debt is the accumulated deficits and
surpluses over time so let me give you
an example if in year one of a country
you run a fifty dollar deficit at the
end of that year the country has accrued
a debt of $50 you exist for one year you
ran a fifty dollar deficit your debt is
now 50 bucks if in the next year you run
a 25 dollar surplus what happens at the
end of that year is your debt has gone
down from $50 to $25 right year one
deficit is 50 bucks year two surplus is
twenty five bucks at the end of year two
the accumulated debt is $25 you went $50
negative after year one and you paid off
25 of it with your surplus in year two
okay I mean I apologize some people
write in and they say David please stop
talking to the audience like they're
little kids that's not what I'm trying
to do every time I do this people are
confused about the two issues so we were
told that the tax cuts would pay for
themselves because they would generate
massive growth and they would move us
from having a deficit each year to
having a surplus which would start
chipping away at the national debt
eventually if Trump has eight years in
office completely paying off the
national debt now none of that stuff is
happening okay the tax cuts have added
to the deficit increases in defense
spending which by the way were favored
not only by Republicans but even by many
Democrats as well those are increasing
the deficit and we are not on track
we're not on track to even pay off any
of the debt
never mind pay it off completely in
eight years so those are the facts now I
do think every time we talk about this
we should consider whether it needs to
be reframed and what I mean by that is
the debt and deficit is a political
football okay Republicans say the most
important thing is paying off the debt
and balancing the budget when there
a Democrat in the White House regardless
of whether that Democrat has actually
slowed down deficit growth which Barack
Obama did when Republicans are running
they run on promises to do this really
important thing start paying off debt
generate a surplus but then when they
are in office as we saw under george w
bush as we're seeing in a cartoonishly
exaggerated fashion under donald trump
they just explode the deficit and they
always claim that they're doing it they
either deny that they're doing it even
though we have the numbers and that's
what we see or they will argue that
there were extenuating circumstances
whereby it made sense to a deficit spend
like for example when we decided we were
going to heroically spread democracy to
Iraq and/or punish Iraq for their
nonexistent involvement in 9/11 right
that the reason we it made sense to
spend all that money in Iraq changed
once we figured out Iraq had nothing to
do with 9/11 but still we were given
reasons why it made sense so what we
have today in the end is an unsurprising
status quo we were told before Trump was
elected what he wants to do with tax
policy is not going to generate all of
this winning and growth and start paying
off the debt with surpluses in fact it's
going to increase the deficit that is
exactly what happened none of this is
surprising so that gets us to the
question of if and how Democrats should
talk about this on the campaign trail
because on the one hand Trump made
promises and he broke the promises and
he's doing the opposite of what he
promised to do it seems as though
exposing that on the campaign trail for
the eventual Democratic nominee would be
a worthwhile thing but on the other hand
we know number one that it's just a
political football we know number two
that in reality the narrative over
deficit bad surplus good cutting
spending good or whatever else it's not
actually a modern and nuanced
understanding of debt and deficit what
we should be asking in reality is when
does it make sense for governments to
deficit spend and when doesn't it make
sense so do we want a deficit spend to
line the bank accounts of the already
rich and corporations including just
providing money for them to buy back
stocke the answer is no do we want the
deficit spend to improve society for
large numbers of people improve their
ability to live good healthy lives have
access to health care work jobs that
they like without being tied to mediocre
health insurance programs okay now we
have something to talk about so I think
that it is important for Democrats not
to ignore the issue of debt and deficit
but we can't allow the right to continue
framing the narrative because they win
they talk about it one way when it's a
Democrat in office they take office then
they just say oh no the numbers aren't
actually what they are you can't believe
the numbers that were actually getting
from from the Congressional Budget
Office and from the Treasury they win
with the framing that we have and lastly
please please please can we stop falling
for this stupid idea that tax cuts for
the rich are so good for the economy
that they reduce the deficit and
actually increase government revenue we
didn't even need another example we had
plenty of examples before Donald Trump's
tax reform plan but we can now add the
Trump tax reform plan to the list of tax
cuts for the rich and corporations that
did not cause so much growth that they
paid for themselves my question to you
is do you think Republicans even believe
this idea that tax cuts for the rich pay
for themselves or do they know that it's
BS but just keep repeating it because
these are the tax cuts that they want
that's my question to you today let me
know what you think if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning
and you can access the entire library of
fun easy-to-use online courses for free
for two months by using the link
underneath this video two months of
learning something that's totally new to
you something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free
by clicking the link under this video